everybody should take so this is the
course link let me post the link again
in the chat box it's called the
introduction to bi-informatics course
once you come across to this course you
will notice that
this course has an introductory video
so this is this
if you click on this first link you will
notice that it will take you to the
first
lesson of this course so this lesson
starts with a form
you may have already taken the
introduction to bioinformatics course or
you may just be starting out
this form helps us to understand more
about who you are
and what your interest in relation to
bioinformatics
biology or biotechnologies or any other
related domain so we have
also your research interest that you can
fill out right here
so please go ahead and fill out the form
and then you would be once you submitted
you would be able to start with the
course and you will notice that there
are a lot of images there's a lot of
text that defines
what is bioinformatics what are the
different applications of bioinformatics
and each section you have to complete
to move on to the next section so right
so this is the introduction to
bioinformatics course that i hope that
everybody here would be able to go ahead
and look at
and now for everybody who is also
interested in rnac
so this is the transcriptomics courses
now let me also post the link
to this course in the chat box
here you would find that the first
lesson is the biology of
transcription and then we have rna
quantification
rna-seq and ngo sequencing and each of
these lessons start with a video so you
will be noticing that there is a video
here that you can first play
to understand what this course is all
about
and i also want to introduce you to our
slack channel so this
channel is for our participants only
what we do
as part of the slack channel is help
participants communicate with our team
in an effective manner beyond the
sessions
so these are the few resources at the
beginning that we will be using
and now let me go back to my
presentation
and take you through to the next
resource
so one of the other resources that we
will be using is the tbio info platform
for bioinformatics processing and
analysis of
rna-seq data the platform will include
demo pipelines as well as data
management and
analysis cloud infrastructure to run
bioinformatics pipelines different
stages of analysis are performed in
different sections of this multi-omics
platform
and we will also have exercises designed
to explain
code for these types of visualizations
in both
r and python from the very basics to the
cutting edge
loading transformation visualization as
well as
complex discovery of patterns in real
data sets
used by researchers to study and
understand biological phenomena at the
molecular level
so once our understanding of rna-seq is
clear
from the courses exercises and lessons
we will also use curated data sets on
malaria to study the efficacy of
vaccines and drugs
associated with resistance and the
complexity of host pathogen vector
interaction
our team has already prepared a number
of research data repositories and
databases that will help
participants identify high impact data
sets for analysis
besides malaria we will discuss various
applications of rnac to the study of
sars cov2 where selective pressure on
various proteins will lead to the
emergence of new variants
such changes are already being seen as a
result of increased immunity vaccination
and other host pathogen
dynamics this whole process
will help you to apply these methods
that you will learn to curated and new
data sets and develop
independent projects that showcase what
you have learned in the context of a
personal portfolio of
projects as a result anyone who is
starting on this journey
from today can start developing a
project of their own
like our previous omics logic
participants
all of whose projects are displayed here
and this is exactly how we will be using
a combination of
online sessions self-guided study
materials and
practical assignments for an immersive
experience
that has proven to be effective in our
omics logic programs
so starting from today our participants
will be interacting
with our mentors and
if you are new to our platform let me
introduce you to
our mentors here we have dr harpreet
kaur who is our omits logic trainer
and an expert bioinformatician she
mentors the sessions
and will guide you through the program
her
era of specialization is in genomics
dr mohit masumdar has a phd in
computational biology and over 10 years
of experience working with industry and
academia
he will also work with participants on
their research projects
is our ceo and co-founder his experience
in research in academia
has led to many research labs and
university collaborations
and has been recognized for the
simplified approach to omics analysis
for education
now i would like to invite elia to speak
more about
transcriptomics for infectious diseases
over to you elia
thank you thank you very much pizza
and uh welcome everyone to this first
session
uh before we begin let me just briefly
introduce myself
my name is elia brodsky i'm the
co-founder and ceo of pine biotech
our vision is to enhance human health by
enabling biological research and
discovery with relevant data solutions
and expert support and so this program
is really designed around simplifying
some of the bioinformatics complexities
to allow as many participants as
possible
to gain a better sense of how to apply
bioinformatics tools
to specifically rnac transcriptomic data
in the context of infectious so as a
company
our mission is to simplify
bioinformatics and advance research
through our modular and intuitive
multi-arguments platform that is powered
by human experience and artificial
intelligence and so
this platform was developed at the
talbot bioinformatics research center
which is focused on development of novel
algorithms
as well as making them user friendly so
that anyone like
you or i could actually try and use and
compare
and decide which algorithms are actually
needed
for the analysis that we would like to
do but what we've discovered
is that this actually does require a
serious approach
to how we present the different
challenges
research questions and these tools in
the context
of the logic of analysis so that's why
this program is called omixlogic
and specifically the program that we are
starting today
is called omixlogic transcriptomics
so what i will do in my part of the
presentation
is expand a little bit on some of the
topics that we will be going through
to set the stage for this training
program so the training will be focused
on transcriptomics
uh specifically how we can leverage
rna-seq data
to study infectious disease from the
perspective of host response
disease progression and host pathogen
vector interaction
so to do to do this we will discuss the
various aspects of rna-seq data analysis
including
how to convert raw reads from sequencers
to structured data how to perform
exploratory analysis
and clustering to understand some
patterns and
uh what we are looking at in the data as
a whole how to identify important genes
through differential gene expression and
feature selection
how to understand biological signals
through pathway enrichment
and how to perform single cell
deconvolution of bulk rna-seq
and analysis of single cell rna-seq data
so we really have a lot planned for this
program
so as a result of completing this
program we hope that each participant
will gain
a clear picture of rna-seq data
processing analysis
and biological interpretation using big
data analysis cloud-based tools
we will also learn about how machine
learning is used to find
complex patterns in big data and how
statistics could be applied to such data
to extract
meaningful insights what's important is
that this program is best suited for
those interested in research
projects so you will have the
opportunity to develop an
independent research project question or
proposal
after completing all of the program
sessions you will earn a certificate of
excellence if you have designed and
completed
an advanced project or a certificate of
participation for completing the basic
training and so
today is the first session and what we
will do in today's session
is just start talking about what is
rna-seq data and what is transcriptomics
and how we actually get started to think
about
the measurements that we are going to be
taking with rna-seq data
now for those of you raising your hand
or trying to ask a question
i will pause for questions after a
little bit
of an introduction
okay so let's start with some basics
what is transcriptomics
and how is it different from other omics
onyx technologies like next generation
sequencing can be used to explore the
roles
relationships and actions of the various
types of molecules
that make up the cells of an organism so
there are many types of omics data that
could be generated
using a variety of techniques one of
them
is next generation sequencing and it is
also known as
high throughput sequencing the data from
high throughput sequencing can reveal
important information about genomic
variants in genomics
epigenetic regulation mechanisms like
epigenomics
but transcriptomics is needed to
generate data about
mrna expression and it allows us to
study
patterns or levels of gene and
isoform expression including how these
genes define
pathways or how they are modulated
through different levels of gene
expression or through alternative
splicing
mrna exploration can be studied using a
variety of methods
and this includes northern blot analysis
ribonuclease protection assay
and quantitative reverse transcriptase
coupled polymerase chain reaction
or rt-pcr so what are these methods
right before we kind of jump into
next generation sequencing so northern
blotting
is a very um relatively easy method to
use and has become one of the
widely used methods for characterizing
mrna size and relative
abundance northern blotting is the only
one of these techniques that allows
mrna size determination and so it has
been a method for detecting mutations
that result in abnormal mrna size
but as a quantitative technique northern
blotting represents several limitations
because of its inability to control for
the efficiency of rna
transfer and membrane binding and so it
is
a semi-quantitative technique that is
most suitable for determining
relative concentrations of mrna species
that occur
in moderate to high abundance so
then ribonuclease protection assay rpa
is right here so rpa is performed by
hybridization in solution of labeled rna
probe to an
rna sample containing the target rna
and after hybridization excess single
stranded probe and non-target rna
is digested by treatment with rna's
mixture
the protected probe target rna hybrid
may be analyzed
by denaturing poly acrylic gel
electrophoresis page or by precipitation
and filter binding for quantitation by
scintillation counting
okay so structure of a typical
transcription template
for synthesizing an rna probe cdna
sequence corresponding to the target
mrna is subcloned downstream of a
bacteriophage
rna polymerase promoter so one of the
um one of the aspects of
this method makes it a
semi-easy method of
using this technique to quantify mrna
but
it is prone to mistakes and various
technical issues
another technique like i mentioned was
rtpcr which is a technique of choice to
quantify
low abundance mrna species and detect
mrna in
small number of cells because as you can
imagine
pcr amplifies the low quantity rna so it
allows us to
detect what is in there and so
it should detect cdna derived from a
single mrna molecule
and so in practice even though it should
detect
even one 10 or more mrna copies are
required because of the relative
inefficiency
of the reverse transcriptase reaction
required to convert
mrna to cdna for subsequent
amplification
and so uh what all of these techniques
led to
is the emergence of what's called
microarray
and microarrays are also hybridization
based
and so what that means is that
microarray hybridization assays are
widely used
for a variety of research in clinical
applications where
a known mrna transcript is needed
unlike most historical platforms for
clinical rna measurement
these these
microarrays can contain thousands and
thousands of predefined
mrna probes so even specific splicing
transcripts could be included on these
uh
probes so how is
rna-seq different from all of these
methods
rna as opposed to rna-seq as opposed to
all of these kinds of
platforms that we already discussed
rna-seq has a wider dynamic
range as you can see right here what's
important about rna
is when it is translated there is an
alternative combination
of exons that are spliced together to
actually form the transcript that will
become
a protein through translation and so
this is called a
wider dynamic range which means that you
can
detect many more types of variations
because
uh as opposed to a textbook
understanding of
this alternative splicing actually it
can happen in
aberrant ways right in many different
ways in cancer for example sometimes
introns are known to be included in the
actual transcript and so
you would have no way of detecting that
using these
previous first generation techniques uh
so
and rnaseq is really a powerful
method uh that avoids some of the
technical limitations
such as varying pro performance and
cross hybridization
rnac can measure the expression levels
of thousands
of genes simultaneously and provide
insights into functional pathways
and the regulatory networks and
biological systems
in addition rnac can provide novel
insights into alternative splicing
unannotated exons and novel transcripts
and most importantly such detail has
already proven to yield significant
discoveries
in many research areas like i mentioned
in cancer and others
so actually in our next session we will
cover a lot more in detail the actual
process of next generation sequencing
how this data is
prepared but i'll briefly touch on it
today as well so next generation
sequencing technology captures dna
sequence
and generates digital data right so the
objective here is to take
a biological sample extract the mrna
convert it to cdna and then use
pieces of sheared cdna to
prepare a flow cell that is full of
these
uh prepared sequences that could then be
amplified through
a solid phase pcr blue bridge
amplification
and then from reading of the signal by
converting each letter to a specific
colored signal
we can get accurate reading of the
signal coming from each cdna
so the machine uses image analysis to
capture each letter in the flow cell
fragments by analyzing
visual patterns and converting them to a
sequence of letters
typically next generation sequencing uh
okay i think my screen got
turned off okay yeah uh we can see your
screen
here yeah okay so typically
the reads coming out of the sequencer
are anywhere between 30
and 300 base pairs long even though
today
with the evolving technology for rna
sequencing
very high lengths of reeds can also be
achieved
thousands of nucleotides per read and
that's an exciting new development
in rna-seq importantly rna sequencing
allows for the detection of the wide
variety of rna species including
mrna non-coding rna pathogen rna
chimeric gene fusions transcript
isoforms and splice variants and
provides the capability to quantify
known predefined rna species as well as
discover
novel and rare rna transcriptarians
within
a single sample in addition to
differential expression and detection of
novel transcripts
rna-seq also supports the detection of
mutations and germline variation for
hundreds to thousands of expressed
genetic variants
facilitating assessment of allele
specific expression of these variants
and so here we will focus on the
application of rna-seq for infectious
disease diagnosis
for example in rna-seq samples you can
extract
enough reads to even detect presence of
a particular pathogen
for example rna-seq is used to detect
clinically important rna viruses in
regular screening of tissues
like hiv ebola west nile
dengue hepatitis a b and d
kaksaki and influenza viruses as well as
severe acute respiratory syndrome stars
and middle east
respiratory syndrome mers coronaviruses
so a lot of these applications are
typically
not the typical approach to study
rna-seq but
we will discuss how rnac could be used
in that so specifically for pathogen
mrna measurements it could be
useful as a marker of infection right so
you can detect
for example low abundance of viral
dna or rna present um and
it can be specifically important in
cases of low level infection
right so for example uh bacteremia
and cerebrospinal fluid infections are
very important for low
detection and it could be a better
predictor of disease compared to direct
genomic detection for example
the simple detection of human papilloma
virus or hpv dna
is not sufficient to diagnose
hpv-related squamous cell carcinoma
even though hpv dna is detectable in
about 14 percent of healthy control
women
so rna-based diagnostics to detect hpv
have been developed
so there's a lot of important
applications and considerations to not
just detect a particular
dna sequence but actually to look at the
expression of specific
genes of these pathogens on the host
side
we can also look at the host response
for example
mrna signatures that could be useful to
monitor
even specific infections for example
upregulation of specific host immune
factors like interferon beta
1 or ifnb1 interferon lambda 2
if and l2 and infrared interferon lambda
3
if and l3 were recently demonstrated for
genotype 3
hcv infection which is associated with
accelerated
liver fibrosis and is an independent
risk factor for heptacellular carcinoma
compared to non-genotype 3-htv infection
host microrna gene interactions during
the infection
response are also proving to be a
fruitful source of potential diagnostic
biomarkers for specific infection
and even distinguishing between active
and latent
infections as we know in hepatitis
for example the use of such biomarkers
to discriminate between latent infection
and
active disease with m tuberculosis
right so there's a lot of applications
of rna-seq
for detection accurate characterization
of
pathogen-caused diseases as well as
measurement of host responses we know in
covid for example we can do
this distinguish between acute uh
disease stages as opposed to mild
disease stages
using rna-seq data as well and so
obviously
in many of these the challenge is to
integrate
and explore detailed data
using a cloud platform that leverages
big data analysis on the cloud as
opposed to
more visualization and statistical
analysis of your data
on the laptop and so beeps already
mentioned this platform
when you are registering on the omics
logic
website when you go
and you make your registration you
should receive an email
that will also come with password
details
so when you go to login if you have not
done this yet
and you create an account right here
once you sign
up and fill out these details and please
uh
follow up with an email check after you
do this
you will actually see your information
to log
in to the server platform
so to kind of understand some of the
specific details that we will cover in
the program related to transcriptomic
data analysis
please go with me to this link
and let me know once you've had the
chance
to log in okay so so this is the link
and please put in number one
or yes or something like this in the
chat box so that i know that you are
with me here on this platform
okay i'm just going to give it a couple
of minutes again if you don't have
access to the platform you don't know
what your password is or how to log in
just simply registering for free on the
learnomicslogic.com platform
will allow you to get that in your email
okay thank you rasheed rashid is already
here has anyone
else been able to okay thank you dua
um and timothy okay thank you very much
let's wait
um for at least a couple more okay
excellent
okay so um as you can see here we have
the areas of analysis this is
the section for processing next
generation sequencing data
and here the first one that you will see
is transcriptomics and you can hover
over some of these icons to kind of
learn more
about each section so let's first
look at this rna-seq chip seek and so
here you will see
a few different examples that we will
look at today just to kind of understand
what we will learn in the full course
typically when we do our training in
transcriptomics we go through this first
example with
cell line projects and so this cell line
project
is a cancer project but today we will
speak about applications of
transcriptomics to infectious diseases
and so let's look over here at this demo
called sf9
unmapped reads
okay so once you click here you will get
into a
demo section of the platform in other
words you don't have to upload data
we'll introduce you to some data sets in
just a little bit
but for now you can just go to this
section
again for those of you that are
following along right here it's called
demo
sf9 unmapped reads
okay so once you are here you will see
that
each button here corresponds with a step
and so each step allows us to identify
uh okay actually sorry i
see that um there's something let's go
to another one
um let's go to this one cell line
and see that that there's some issue
with that demo
because i didn't see anything pop up so
okay so
here um uh again we will see an overview
of some of the important logical steps
for rna-seq data processing and you can
see that there are actually several
options here that will open up once you
create this pipeline
okay so here we have start and i can
choose to go to any one of these
sections
now a lot of times when you think about
processing rna-seq data
you're thinking about mapping the host
data onto the reference genome
to understand the alignment as the first
step
yes rashmi did you have a question
okay if you do have a question feel free
to put it in the chat box
yes go ahead
okay so one of the things that i want to
point out is that
typically before alignment itself it is
useful to pre-process
the data to clean it from certain
artifacts we'll learn our next session
why we do that
so let's go ahead and clean up right
here
some of the adapters and that pcr
amplification from that bridge
amplification
and then we will see that we have two
options
for our next step one is hisat2 so let's
select that one
what hisa2 does is it improves on the
previous
algorithms called top hat and top hat 2
and allows us to do an accurate
alignment
with alternative splicing junctions
excuse me and uh what you will see here
is that one important output
from this hisat2 algorithm are
some unmapped reads that have already
been cleaned up
for each one of our samples so whenever
we're looking for
a pathogen potentially
that has some transcription already for
one of its genes
we want to identify that by looking at
weeds that have not been mapped
to the reference genome so this is a
human sample
we will take the human sample and try to
detect
unmapped reeds that can lead to
discovery
of those pathogen reads that we can then
detect using mapping to a database and
so we'll talk about that
in one of our future sessions but here
we'll go to hisat2
you can see that what it combines is
mapping on genome and mapping on
junction to detect exons then we will
construct
isoforms by clicking here which means
that we will detect
how many different transcripts are
available
in our data by linking together
all of the present exons using those
junctions
of splicing points on the genome
then we need to create a gtf file we'll
talk a little a lot more about the
various types of
annotation steps that are important in
this pipeline
and typically what we think about of a
gtf file is an
annotation of all of the important
positions that we look for
when we analyze our rna-seq data so
we'll go through
this step for gtf processing and now
that we have this gtf
we can actually map our reads for
quantification so here we are
going to perform mapping on transcripts
using bowtie2t
and create a table of expression using
rsem or rna-seq using expectation
maximization so this is a
a method to understand
significance of amplification and
do some downstream quantification
with normalization uh for our
gene expression table and so after we do
this we can perform
a differential gene expression and this
differential gene expression will help
us detect which genes are differentially
expressed
in our data using dc2 or
hr and you will see that some of these
outputs are going to be
very easy to read and so the next step
after this
what we recommend doing after today's
session for those of you that have
completed the registration is to start
learning
about each one of these uh specific
uh places that we are going to be
um that we are going to be doing
throughout this program
okay so here you will click on end
and now you can see some of these uh
outputs from dc2 you can see that
there are some mapping statistics d seek
for
expression of genes isoforms and
you will see all of your results from
rsem here
as well so this is an important part
because
the input files here are actually
gigabytes and gigabytes
of data that would not be practical to
use on your local computer on your local
system
okay so does anyone have any questions
about what we did so far
i see a question will this recording be
made available to us
after the session today yes beeps say if
you could please
uh take the link from youtube we have
this streaming live right now
so you will be able to see the recording
after we are done
maybe so you could post that there as
well
and we will follow up by email to those
of you that are
interested okay any other questions
before i move on
okay so what this platform will allow us
to do
is to start applying some of these
rna-seq
methods to data sets that we might be
interested
in exploring now what types of data sets
are going to be curated for this program
using various infectious diseases
that we're going to be studying uh
one obvious interest that many many have
is the understanding of source code 2
infection disease progression and
variable clinical manifestations
of this disease in patients
as you can imagine any virus
is a complex protein machinery that
actually uses in a very effective way
all of the encoded proteins
to make a variety of tools
to subvert how it is recognized by the
immune system
what responses it causes in a variety of
tissues
cells and organs and how it actually
hijacks the machinery of the cell to
produce
its own its own virions
and so we'll take a look at how rna-seq
data can be helpful in
analyzing such gene expression profiles
from infected cells and cell cultures
to understand the complexity of this
protein machinery
we will also look at how sarcoscope 2
interferes with the typical
biological pathways of this
immune response to evade the immune
detection
and to modulate the immune responses to
achieve its goal
of infecting cells at a rapid pace we'll
also look at how
the design of experiments could be
used to modulate different
genomic construction of viral genomes
and then study the application of
the response in the host so that we
understand
what is the function of particular
proteins and genes encoded
in these viral genomes importantly we
will
look at some of the standard tools like
we did today
we'll talk about how to use statistical
analysis
conceptually to start studying the
different variable
variable infection and specific types of
and specific types of conditions that
were designed as a part of the
experiment
all the way to more advanced and complex
methods like
regression that could be used to detect
a variable
of various sorry a variety of
outcomes including factors that
influence our observed data and the
outcomes that we can observe through
integrating with clinical data or our
biological
interpretation of that data and so we
will use
gene set and pathway enrichment analysis
to then
talk about biological interpretation of
what we observe in these conditions that
we are studying
uh there's a question um
okay so yes if you're just joining and
that's a good place to kind of talk
about
so we are talking about this
transcriptomics program it's starting
today
this is the first session for this
training program
uh what we are doing in this program uh
first of all is we
i have briefly described what the
program will cover and what we will be
talking about but this program is
actually going to be quite
comprehensive so we'll take some more
time for us to go through all of these
topics
and the topics that we will cover is the
ngs rnac technology and applications
how to process raw data and get a table
of expression
uh how to perform differential gene
expression using statistical
considerations about multiple testing
how to identify statistical correlation
and regression
use data science for omics using r and
python
which we will cover at the later part of
the
program and then also how to identify
data sets to start practicing what you
learn
and actually develop a project a
research project of your own
so hopefully that answers your question
there as well
so for the purposes of time i'm going to
skip over some of the
additional methods and i want to pass it
on to
dr harpreet coor who is going to be one
of your
program mentors to talk about some of
the curated data sets that we have
prepared
to allow us to apply these rna-seq
analysis methods
to infectious disease projects so dr
karor
i'll pass it on to you now thank you
and can you make me just co-host
okay thank you
hello everyone so today we are going to
talk about
uh what are important data sets are
there of regarding
infectious diseases especially related
to the transcriptomics data
so here we have like the first
repository that i am going to talk about
we have already curated
uh some of the important data set and
that i will share so the first
repository that uh we are going to talk
about
uh is jio so here you will find a data
set so there are some of the important
things that i
just want to mention so here under the
series metrics file just give me a
second i
just buy just give me a second
okay so let me first explain you
actually on jio
what kind of information is there and
how you should proceed
to retrieve a data set so if you already
have some
geo id which is also known uh start with
gse the gse means series id
so you can search here under the geo
session number
so then here you will find like actually
that this data
is related with which study so in the
title you will find that
and then they also describe the summary
so like from this study it this
particular data has been taken
and actually uh what originally authors
have done with this data
so then under the overall design you
will get information regarding
kind of how many samples are there for
example here
you can see like with this uh specific
data set here are 108 samples that are
paired uh post pre and post challenge
for 54 individuals then 190
198 data sets are again for the pre
and post challenge for 99 individuals so
they are
it contains two types of samples
then under the citation you will find
the complete link of the original
publication
from which this data has been taken and
submitted to the jio
so then most important thing actually
where you will find this data
important where the metadata is
available and where
there is raw or processed data so the
uh first the already original raw data
under the relation you will find this
link like bio project and sra
so this especially if you are interested
in high throughput sequencing data so
the raw data is available
either under the bio project of sra so
you will find those links
related to your high throughput raw data
then is about metadata so
here the third file under the download
family
which is series matrix file so here you
will find metadata regarding high
throughput or microarray data
so especially if it is uh
microarray data in that case you will
find the process data as well
under the series matrix so then
here under the supplementary file
you will find the process data for high
throughput sequencing
while raw data for any microarray study
so then now i think let me share some of
the datasets with you
and also demonstrate to you how we can
actually obtain the data set
so here i have provided some of the
links and let's
directly go to the repository
so just let me know if you're able to
log into the jio
so first let me show you how actually we
can find data
from the jio which is gene expression
omnibus
so let me know once you are here
so type yes if you are able to
go to geo or which is gene expression
omnibus
so let me paste its link in the chat
okay okay so
here for example you if you are
interested in
you know malaria or some infections this
is like over 19
so first you need to create your query
for example here i am searching for a
malaria
so i just created my query directly
malaria so once i created that and i
will get
this link so first i need to click on
this number like nearly
that is 4046 if i click on this
number
so i will direct it to this uh interface
on the jio so then from here itself i
can
select top organism so on the right side
of
this interface you you will if you are
interested like in a particular kind of
organism you can select that
for example if you want to extract only
those
data cells which are associated with the
plasmodium falci forum
so you can select this
so then what kind of data that you are
interested whether you are interested in
high throughput sequencing or microarray
data
so what we can do under the study type
if you just
click on the customize
and this pop-up will come so here
you can select whether you are
interested in high throughput sequencing
data or a microarray data so
under the expression for filing by error
array is
data generated by microarray profiling
technique
and like expression for filing by high
throughput sequencing one can find data
here
so then if you're interested in coding
or the non-coding you can select those
so then you can go to show and then you
need to click
that particular uh your selective
filter for example i had already
selected expression for filing by
high throughput sequencing right so here
you will get like now we have data set
nearly 39 data sets that are associated
with the expression for filing by high
throughput sequencing
specifically related with the plasmodium
falciparum
now as the number is reduced like
now we are left with only 39 data sets
so one can explore these kind of data
set individually
so for example the first data first data
set is associated with the single cell
label so one can if somebody is
interested
in single cell similarly here the second
study is also again associated with the
single cell sequencing
transcriptional heterogeneity and
stochastic gene expression in plasmodium
size so someone if you are depending
upon your research interest you can
take these data sets so i had already
find few of
some of the important data set here for
example
this particular study here uh let me
share it link with you so i have already
curated like
seven uh nearly ten data sets uh related
to the
malaria so let me paste a link for
one of the data so that to me it looks
interesting
so here if you look at this particular
study
here you will get details regarding
first regarding
uh the data set this data is associated
with big steps
so here are the molecular hallmarks of
naturally acquired immunity to the
malaria
so then you will find what authors have
actually done
under the summary so they have tried to
understand the immunity
to malaria can be required to natural
exposure to plasmodium sarcoplasm
but only after that years of repeated
infections
then typically this immunity is acquired
by adults
and confers protections against diseases
but
not up infections
so the first to understand the mechanism
of this community
are integral to the development of a
bacteria that would mimic the
induction of other community in the
children so
they have like then you can go to
details like
here under the citation you will find
complete publication
so here let me share it link as well
so this is like whenever you actually
going through a data
uh or taking a data you need to go
through original publications
what authors have already done with this
data so that when you're actually
asking your question you should not be
like asking the same question which only
the
authors have addressed or anyone who
have already exist
some may be uh in a different study so
you need to make sure
that your research project should be
noble enough
so now let's come back to the data set
here under the overall design you will
find how many samples are there
then here the data that i was talking
about
like so we have fbk
data so under if i already look at what
is this
data so here we have total 198 samples
so
you if you click and you uh you can find
all the samples
just to understand actually how this
data is processed
if you just click on one sample
you will get complete information
regarding how this data is processed
for example here under the data
processing
authors have explained so what they have
generated they have spkm values were
obtained from the top
topper algorithm so then they also use
the genome
which is grch 37
so then also they explain which version
of profit they have used if you're
looking at your sequence visa
math so using the topper version too
so you will get this information then
the supplementary data what
supplementary data contains
so here because for the high throughput
sequencing
or technique on the jio under the
supplementary data you will find process
data
so under the supplementary file but now
for what it contains so it is
delimited file include ftk and values
for the g
and transcript isoform and read con
per gene then what kind of information
they
have or the metadata information for
this particular data
so here they have uh me to under the
characteristic
you will find that information so here
if you look at the
characteristics they have provide
information regarding
two uh important characteristics one is
sign point that is
force infection second is infection
infection
isn't like cure that is regarding the
one sample if you just want to
understand what is this data
now go back to the complete data
so here under the uh series method file
you will find
metadata now let me download this data
so you can download and find the
metadata here then the supplementary
file
is here so similarly if you are
interested in raw data so you will find
links for the bio project now let me
take you
and show you these bio presets and sre
this is
sra where we will get sequence
read data so this is the bio project for
which you will get
a link for both for sra and what is this
project is about so you will get
complete
details here as well so then this is sra
that is
that is sequence reader type so you will
have the fastq file data here right
so now let me show you
what kind of data and how we can
actually generate a simple metric
uh from the series matrix and what kind
of metadata metadata is there
so let me take one example
just give me a second
okay so here this is the series matrix
data right
so the series matrix data that
which contain metadata so i have pasted
that in
excel af because that is
that is gzip file so why unzipping we
will get this
metadata so here you will get first
the top part contains information
regarding the study itself
then here then it start with sample
like here sample type title so from here
onward you will have information
regarding each of these samples
so for example here so this is like
another data so
here we have like sample title then
under the sample underscore
characteristics
which contain actually the metadata
information
so this is like if i just copy these
sample characteristics and this id
so i have already copied this here
so now i have important metadata
regarding this particular data set
so let me share this id as well
sorry
so here you will get like time point
right
exactly the day outcome so all the
metadata information is available in the
series metrics but
you just need to like here again against
the sample id
here in the jio they usually uh give
always a sample id with the gsm so the
sample
id always start with the gsm followed by
some number which is always
a unique number so then you will find
these are different
clinical or demographic characteristics
related to the
specific data so then this is
the data that we have like here they
have provided the gene
gene symbol in the first column followed
by this entries id
and gene id so from here onward if i'm
looking at this particular data here we
have
these samples so in the columns we have
samples except
these four starting rows so these
sometimes only
authors provide like only transcript id
or sometimes they provide
uh sometimes they provide additional
information like
gene's name that is gene symbol rather
not a name
so then gene id so this kind of
information depending on authors
sometimes provide you this information
as well
so here from on here onward
we have the sample id so you can always
match these sample ids
with the metadata for example i am
looking at this particular id
where is this id is available so what i
can do
i can look at my metadata which i have
prepared
so this is this sample similarly we can
actually map about
all the ids with the metadata
information
then we can ask the different questions
depending upon what information we
have right
so similarly i have like already curated
like
nearly 10 data sets so similarly you can
find another data
here this is this one
so this is regarding transcription
response to our
rts standard enzyme and this particular
treatment vaccine in controlled human
malaria infection so similarly if you
look at this data
here we have this information like this
data is taken from 46
individual and they have like already
concluded
nearly 670 samples so
each of these samples this is like very
large data
so if you like somebody is interested in
supervised machine learning
in that scenario if you want to uh
prepare and want to generate a good
model in that
in such scenario usually we need large
number of samples
so this kind of data is very useful then
you are doing that uh
supervised machine learning so then like
here i have already shown you under the
supplementary file you will get the
process data
so particularly in this study so let me
share this data as well
so this is high again a high throughput
sequencing data so where you can look at
like this is a high throughput
sequencing data expression profiling by
high throughput sequencing
so then here under the
supplementary files you have two types
of data one is
log to expression values so other one
raw raw font value so this is already
txt file and they have
produced the tables so then if you want
to look at what are the
important that uh important metadata
information you will have
so you can again just to check before
downloading
anything you again check under the
characteristics you will find this
information like patient id
gender uh authenticity whether it's
african
or heritage or african american then the
what if statement is given
then whether the protection is already
there or not so they have provide this
kind of
information right so then you want to
look at how this particular data
data is processed so authors have used a
line star
uh star allow for the alignment
uh they have used the star algorithm
then sequence reads
uh what filter for low quality sequence
in the presence of and then map to the
hd
19 whole genome using star aligner
particular this version then they used
gene console calculated using ht6 when
all the data is quantified
as india has already explained you like
there are the number of different steps
uh for the preprocessing
which removes duplicates and the
adapter sequences or any non uh
technical sequences
then the your clean leads are mapped
against
uh and reference genome
or reference transcriptome then you
quantify the gene expression so what is
uh what are the algorithm used for
mapping or
quantification they have explained that
then in the supplementary data they have
already
normalized gene count tables so this
kind of information you will get and
then you can
uh then you can actually analyze such
data
right so
if you are interested in raw data you
can always go to the raw repositories
but the challenge with the raw data for
example here i was showing you
even just by looking at single file
single file
so the single file is itself like three
this is 3.4 gb
4g uh this is more than 4 gb so
like this is 3.4 2.8 gb so even a single
file
is difficult to handle so to process
such data
we have our server which will
simply generate the gene expression
table which elia
already shown you so here you need not
to
up download your fastq files on your
system so we just
need to create a simple sra run table
so how i can generate sra run table
simply i need to go to so this is my
already data
here so what i can do i can do
so this is the data if you want to use
for the public repository
here you can use run info then you can
create this
files
please go ahead okay
so here we have like after
creating the sra run table we are not
downloading complete
or any of the fastq files but we can do
we can generate our simply
sra run table so let me just give me a
second
so here i have already generated my sra
run table so
what i can do i can give just this sra
run table to produce simple gene
expression table
so for example after uh
so this is my sra run table so which i
just need to copy in some txt
file then i can actually give this table
and process
this uh such a high uh like here we have
hundred samples
so even on an average if i just consider
that one
file is like 4 gb so you will have
otherwise you need to download like 400
more than 400 gb space
even to keep this data so to tackle
such things what we did like you just
need to provide this table
and if i just here with the again just
with that demo
i can show you like this in this the uh
sorry
here under the ngs data particularly you
will find transcriptomic subsection
so here these drop down indicate
indicates
the demo pipeline so for example here we
have already
uploaded one data set that is related to
the another oncology project that is
pdx project so if i just go to this demo
we have already uploaded our data input
data there
so what we can do simply start
by start i am able to upload this data
which is already
loaded because this is demo pipeline
then is pre-processing
so here the primo metric the first
algorithm that is this option getting
highlighted what is
doing that it will remove adapters from
your raw sequencing read
right so then after removing the adapter
then we will go to the pcr clean which
will remove
any duplicate series here
then after the clean these next is how
you are going to align your reads
against the reference transcriptome so
here
number of the algorithms get highlighted
like but i
to g uh then high set similarly there is
stopwatch then this is but
i2t so to align my data
on reference transcriptome here i am
using but i2t
which will align my reads against
reference transcriptome
so then followed by the gene expression
quantification so what i need to do i
can choose
uh any of these algorithm depending upon
the goal of my analysis as well as
what algorithm i have used for the
mapping so depending upon the mapping
algorithm
as well as our goal we can actually then
choose an algorithm to quantify that
expression so like here we can choose
rscm
expression table
so then with the end we can we will able
to complete this
pipeline
so here under the download input file
so here i have like now i have already
clear gene expression table like uh if
you are processing raw data right
so here we will get like this kind of
gene expression table
so now let me share this table would be
similar to that that we have
obtained under the processing data
so this kind of table i have now
so this is fbkm gene expression values
and we will learn what are these fpk and
values or what are these transcript ids
in our next session so here my goal is
how we can take
a raw or the process data from the
public repository
geo related to the infectious disease
right so let me if
let me paste it into the excel itself
so and let me show you so here
if you look at this data here we have
ensembl ids for the transcript followed
by
in the columns we have samples like this
these are er positive samples so you
have to look at like what are those
samples so
this is how we can actually generate a
same gene expression table by processing
so if you have like you don't have any
process data from the public repository
in that case
you can generate gene expression table
using this simple
platform tibanfo server so if you
already have process data then you can
ask
these questions how what kind of uh you
know question now i can ask
like here i was showing you we have a
metadata
in the based on the metadata now i can
actually
ask my question for example i just want
to look at the difference between
prevexing and the post vaccination
changes right so this is like a
vaccine is given to the patient so then
what are the transcriptional changes
taking place
after the vaccination so we can ask this
kind of question like pre
or post vaccination so up then we can
also
uh for the post vaccination then we can
look at like they have given
different day different time points
right so then we can ask questions maybe
already the people are actually
vaccinated early so what are the
different transcriptional changes taking
place in comparison
comparison to the uh subject which have
a given treatment later so we can
actually depending upon what metadata we
have we can ask and create our research
question
so that's if you anyone have any
question
so let me know
and uh the the participants who will
join the program then we can actually
uh help you to create and design your
research query based on the data
that we have curated like we have
already created maybe
uh more than 10 to 20 data sets
like here i was showing you for malaria
similarly we have a data for our data
sets we have that we have created for
uh kobit 19 and ebola infections so we
can act uh we will help you to design
those research questions that you uh
based on which you can design your own
research project
so we start there have many people have
the questions that
how they can join research fellowship
and they message message me about that
if you can explain them sure
yes sure dr harpreet so
okay so suhania has a question here
could we also do the analysis with
r using the same pipeline if you can
continue to
reply that question i will also go ahead
and share my screen
okay so if you can share the screen for
the from the codeomic logic so
so that we can actually directly show
right let's go to learn another question
so
like here under the transcriptomics
course itself so if you just go to the
transcriptomics course
okay give me a moment i'll go to
transcriptomics
so open that and if you just find the
lessons click on the more
load more yeah load more
so here you will like we have various
types of analysis data visualization pca
differential gene expression analysis
supervised machine learning and
unsupervised machine learning algorithm
so we have also
created the codes in our both as
well as in python so you can also do
after you have a gene expression table
then you can actually
run any kind of analysis whether you are
interested to produ uh
to generate a or want to perform
principal component analysis
or whether you are going to do uh
differential gene expression analysis
but to process
raw data because now it is not like
and those codes are not available in our
or the python because the it is that is
working at the in the
behind so there are different scripts so
those are actually
different tools are working at the back
end so but to
further analyze such data once we have
gene expression table we have also
generated both
uh codes for r as well as in the pipe i
hope it is
clear to you know
thank you dr harpreet uh so first i
would want to again
take everybody through the curriculum
once and then get to
some of the project questions that
everybody has here like how
does one get started with their own
project so
this is the syllabus you will find it
here again on this page
so the next session is on 19th which is
monday
so we are going to be talking about
analysis of transcriptomics data
for immune profiling and drug response
for co
for response analysis for copenhagen
drug repurposing
so these the kovit 19 and the malaria
projects are
example projects that we are going to be
using
to learn more about infectious disease
research but that does not mean that
you on your own cannot do another
project so
once we are getting started with the
program and have progressed at least
one to two weeks what we will share with
you is a project form
where you can actually propose your own
project
so if you if you are interested in
working on a project you can start by
thinking already of
what is the project title that you want
to work on or what is the project topic
and start looking at this literature
uh that you have or you are interested
in look at
other research as dr harpreet was saying
that you need to look at the original
publication to understand
what those researchers have done in
terms of this kind of data set
trying to answer this particular type of
a biological question right so
you have to start thinking so if your
end goal is to work on a project
you have to prepare yourself from now
what we are doing
uh at this moment is first preparing you
with the courses
as well as these example projects
in learning and understanding the logic
so that when you are clear about the
logic you are able to apply it to your
own
research question so that is the goal so
we have started here on april 16th
and we'll meet again on monday with our
group of participants to discuss
more about the corporate 19 drug
repurposing
and then we will meet twice every week
to talk
more about transcriptomics data and walk
through
all of these different sessions and then
the program will end on may 20th
so you have almost over
a month to work on not just the
transcriptomics portion but also work on
your own project
so start thinking about it if you are
interested
and if you want to join the program and
and you have not
yet completed your registration i wanted
to quickly show everybody
again so this is the link if you come
it's the same link
just click on get started or the pricing
option
and you will have these three different
options right here
so again i will explain what these three
options mean the beginner
license will give you access to all of
the resources
courses lessons as well as the project
that we discussed today
the intermediate access gives you uh um
access to one-on-one mentor session with
your
mentor or whoever is walking you through
this entire session
and the advanced license gives you an
additional
30 days which means that if you want to
keep on working on your project you can
choose the advanced license that will
give you access
till june 20th so
then you are able to work on your
project as well as
go forward with it so i see here is a
question
from m.a hashmi can this help in
studying cancer system biology so we
definitely do have programs that
are dedicated to cancer biology we just
finished the precision oncology program
and we will be having another
precision medicine program in the summer
and also next week we have a program
from ames
which is all india institute of medical
sciences we are collaborating on a
program on lymphoma
so we have those programs but
this particular program is dedicated to
studying infectious diseases so we are
going to mainly be focusing on
infectious diseases but definitely all
of these courses have a lot of
data set so let me again go back to one
of these courses just to show you
some of these data sets and the lessons
that are there
so if you notice the first course here
is the
tcga liver cancer project so we have a
lot of these courses that we
have on cancer as well as many of the
transcriptomics courses itself has a lot
of data sets on cancer so definitely you
can utilize
these to study about cancer system
biology
as well so
as i introduce you to all the mentors so
you will know that
dr harpreet ilya or dr mohit will be
mentoring the mentoring the session so
it would be either one of them taking
the sessions
and then mostly it would be dr harpreet
helping you out with the project and
guiding you through the sessions
with inputs by the other mentors from
time to time
okay i think i've answered those
questions now i wanted to show you how
the
research process looks like and also
give you like a little
idea of what to expect from a project so
i'll just give you here
some project examples so we have a very
well defined process
of doing or working on your own project
that starts
right with first learning from these
courses that we already said
because they are going to give you the
knowledge
and the understanding or the foundation
about what all these omics topics
are how they relate to each other and
then you start looking
at your project so here we have like a
few guides on this page
that you can understand on how to do
a meaningful project presentation so
this is right for the
end but as we are going through the
program we'll also
go through the different stages like
literature review
then looking at these data sets
understanding what those data sets are
saying as we are doing the analysis
from those data sets then once this is
done
what we have to do is present so you
will also notice that there are a lot of
presentations
and many of these projects have been
actually completed by high school
students for example this project
by amelia so she is a high school
student so
anyone who is interested in working on a
project
can start with a program like this where
they first
learn from a program that which is of
their research interest so it could be
metagenomics it could be transcriptomics
like this it could be infectious
diseases
and then as we move forward
you will be working on your own project
where
you work with your mentor you find a
data set you
start looking at these different
literature
so in regards to that you would be able
to
find out how to work through these so we
have these step-by-step processes
to help you not only work on your
project not only propose your project
but refine that project so that it is
presentable
to a wider number of people in all of
our webinars
and uh in also a lot of our conferences
as well as
we also help our participants present
posters
with from the project that is created
but of course this is done
in a long period of time because project
takes a lot of time and depends on the
topic that you're choosing
so that would completely be dependent on
how much you have learned how much
knowledge you already have
about the topic that you are going to do
your project on
but besides that this is exactly how it
is done
and another question that i have is that
how
will we know which is a one-on-one
mentorship like who is our mentor for
the one-on-one mentorship so
once we are through to the second week
of
the whole program anyone who has an
intermediate license we will reach out
to those
people personally and ask them that if
they
have any requirement of setting up a
one-on-one meeting with the mentor
or they can also reach out to us in case
they have a question and then
it would be decided uh based upon that
conversation who would be mentoring them
on that one-on-one meeting so it could
be
a one-hour one-on-one meeting to help
them out with any of the course
problems or any other problems that they
would be having
so that is exactly how the intermediate
session works
and the advanced license as i mentioned
is again
for not just the mentor sessions but
also the
entire project session and gives you
another 30 days
so i hope that that is very very clear
to everybody if you have any questions
again
you can email me and thank you dr
harpreet for putting my email
in the chat box so you can go through
all of these projects here
all of the participants who have
actually done these projects they have
recorded this video so you can hear from
them
how they've approached the project what
analysis methods they have taken
and if you have any questions you can of
course ask us
so again if you have any question or
query related
to how to join the program then please
reach out to me at the address
that dr harpreet posted marketing at
pine.bio
and i also wanted to introduce you again
to our groups in facebook
and in linkedin so i just
shared the posts on facebook and
linkedin so you will be able to notice
that we keep on sharing very informative
articles as well as talk more about
such free webinars and upcoming programs
in all of these groups so if you're
interested
please feel free to reach out to us
okay so temi tope has another question
again so what is the difference between
the intermediate and the advanced
license
so the intermediate license only gives
you access to one-on-one
sessions you will notice that we have
actually broken down the pricing
and while the advanced license not only
gives you access to all of these basic
and intermediate features but also
an additional 30 days which means
that your entire program access will end
on june 20th instead of may 20th which
is
when the program will end for anybody
who has a basic license or an
intermediate license so this is
completely up to
you regarding what license you want if
you feel that you
want and mentorship only but you do not
have that time to dedicate to an entire
another month of working on a project
then you can choose this or if you just
are a beginner and you're not very sure
about
how to do a project but you're
interested in just learning about what
rnac is and how we can use it
for understanding viral diseases
infectious diseases then please go ahead
and choose the basic license because
this will cover
all of those resources that we have
discussed
the only perk here is the one-on-one
support which is beyond a group session
so if someone is not very
uh very comfortable asking questions in
a group or want some special
time with the mentor just to express all
of their queries then they can choose
for this session so this is completely
up to anybody
so if you already are part of the
program and you want to update please
write it to me via email so that i can
help you out with that
so thank you all again for attending
today's session and if you can have any
questions please feel free to reach out
to us
and i hope that you can also ask us any
questions that you have beyond this
session
and for all of our program participants
we'll see you again on monday i will
send you all the email
uh all the details via email and please
make sure that you have created your
account on learn
that will give you access to the courses
you have your tbio info
passwords ready if you do not have those
please let me know